c'est parce que tu crois stop
[Musique]
le mariage le grand jour c'est parti
derrière
[Musique]
un coup
oxymore
[Musique]
c'est une balade à moitié
il
[Musique]
on y est
en tout
m
les gars c'est l'heure actuelle on
arrive
là on est tous dans la chapelle ont
passé un super moment alors on est un
peu tendue forcément on est un peu
chauvine tonight non le temps on est
content c'est le grand moment donc on
des shoguns tonight aussi c'est assez
dingue à tous les copains au premier
rang et yaël vie ski-doo mari mais à mon
avis elvis il a quelques petits
problèmes de compréhension n'a pas dû le
payer cher parce que ils galèrent avec
mon nom notamment iam si oui à new delhi
c'était bien mieux dit elle
celui ci intègre caméras n'ont pas émis
est mais de quoi
j'ai eu quelques cheveux
damien duteïs paradis et ses doutes sa
guise magali chavez mais les pirates ont
mis en avant à promettre le view son
réseau and there and the good the bad
[Applaudissements]
teaser tous là par ton à la partie non m
un élève
thüga l'embargo tous islamabad
ça va pas passer là je vais tout faire
franchement et le visage du petit ami
koita duras par un collègue de worlds
apart
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le directement c'est vraiment à l'école
pour suivre l'histoire
une belle histoire entre toi s'il est
l'étalon of de tunis
et toi kamin l'étoile montante du paf
the stars in the skies of the past c'est
un honneur d'être avec vous pour pour
une fête cet amour je suis un peu ému je
suis désolé pour toi j'ai été je suis et
je serai toujours ton montre dont
camille tawil fais gaffe à ta gueule si
tu fais n'importe quoi avec mon chéri
cyril camus je vous souhaite le meilleur
pour le présent et pour l'avenir
je vous souhaite de dar k des joies et
un enfant de star avec vous deux merci
motards série termine avec émotion je
vous dis sartec le mariage merci
selon moi ça boume temps on prendra
quelques cours de lecture quand même
[Applaudissements]
tellement monde attend le moment on va
se dire oui
yes mais juste avant il y a un discours
isabelle vous avez fait un petit
discours aussi on sent la patte de la
journaliste adoré faire ça c'est vrai eh
bien regardez
mais je les couplets monsieur
jean-michel next et roland ouais bah
ouais il avait raison prépare t il à
vous avez une heure devant vous je suis
la mère camille cyril cyril camille
démarre mal avant de vous connaître
mabille été terne mais ça c'était avant
avant de découvrir grâce à toi cyril
qu'un sexe comme un mixeur peut-être
multi-usages opposant tenait la
reproduction quand il peut servir à la
production de tom chose appuyez sur un
bouton d'ascenseur quand on a les bras
chargés remet une boisson gazeuse fait
remonter les oeufs en neige indiquer le
bon chemin servir aussi à accrocher une
casquette toi qui des casquettes en a
beaucoup
à ce propos si au début de votre
installation vous êtes fauché comme tous
les jeunes mariés tu pourra à l'occasion
servir de porte manteaux et toi camille
parlons-en
c'est comme compagnon comme cadeau comme
cerveau etc comme cocu si tu laisses
faire mathieu delormeau
bien sûr vous aurez des moments de doute
de crise l'amour ça vient ça va toi
cyril quand tu rentreras par camille te
dira il en penserait quoi ta soeur
jacky 4' plus cool et comme dit le tueur
est en vous serrant les mains éloignés
de l'homo pour enfin vous aimez
aujourd'hui comme hier et bien moins que
demain
[Applaudissements]
chére h quelques minutes un tract et pmp
à vegas il faut qu'on passe les 300 vies
pour que deux personnes un parc bien sûr
en road trip pour 2 personnes massées
pour deux personnes donc c'est une
personne partir avec une autre de vie
jour un bien sûr sur la côte ouest alors
jean-michel aussi afin discours web un
[Rires]
péril
tu avais fait de camille ton poulain sur
d8 aujourd'hui tu veux en faire ta
pouliches c'est bon et comme j'ai déjà
eu l'honneur de voir ton bozizé j'ai
enfin un scoop pour le prochain thé pmp
camille je crois que tu peux encore
continuer longtemps à faire ta chronique
de boue voilà c'est peut-être un détail
pour vous mais pour moi ça veut dire
beaucoup
voilà je vous souhaite bien sûr tout
bonheur du monde et si vous faites des
petits ou fait des petits j'entre en
deux juste pour la blague
voilà et je vous aime la fin tu as
écrite dans la voiture merci jambes
quand on embrasse pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui nous déjà ici c'est mon
bébé ça je m'en fous c'est lui qui a
fait le cas
tout genre il en laye comme ça
les chéris si vous nous rejoignez sur
des mythes rappelez vous n'avez diction
passé les 2 millions de téléspectateurs
vont se marier à las vegas camier mois
et bien le moment est venu de regarder
notre union elvis pour la payer seule
vie ça c'est moi qui le paye cela
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe là est ce que
quelqu'un a eu l'audace n'interfère
cette belle union
tu as quand même pas fait ça quelqu'un a
commis l'irréparable
non non non non il est arrogant une
piste chaude arrogant mais non apple
aurait pas fait ces cas pas fait ça dis
donc toi la regarder jesse marsch
[Musique]
yes moi oui ce que tu as
j'ai la preuve ici j'ai la preuve ici de
mon téléphone
mais nous aussi c'est parce que tu crois
stop il tenait ma famille
[Musique]
à ce jeu
lyonnais
am
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà tout séjour qui nous ont séparés
de cette diffusion on a essayé de faire
bonne figure
comment avez vous besoin en syrie shogun
matthieu delormeau là aujourd'hui je
pense que tout le monde se demande
pourquoi pourquoi vous avez été ça
pourquoi vous avez fait sabatier de
l'ong mais je vais vous le dire mais pas
en présence de camille chalmin qui
mettent ça sur tes yeux mon choix est
fait le et que tu quittes le plateau si
riche de faux pas je vais pas l'écouter
lui emboîtent façon vous et moi c'est
mieux pour toi vu ce que j'ai à dire
crois-moi lé fils va vite mais je vais
où je mets fois que j'ai mis sa vertu
qui te plaît à les iront se fait quitter
le patois camille s'il vous plaît merci
joseph merci à la merci camille combal
alors matthieu delormeau pourquoi il
vous fait ça parce que ce que j'avais à
vous dire cyril c'est que voilà quand je
suis parti là-bas c'était pour me
rapprocher de vous pour espérer vous
convaincre peut-être de m'aimer mais à
force de votre coeur systématiquement
fermées et bien
sans le vouloir et sans le prévoir j'ai
fini par l'ouvrir à quelqu'un d'autre et
je me suis appliqué micoud rapprocher de
camille en fait et ce que je vous ai dit
dans l'oreille c'est que j'en avais la
preuve
et on peut la voir
[Musique]
inquiet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]